انه الرابع والعشرون من يناير ولمن لا
يعلم نحن في اليوم الدولي للتعليم نسخه
هذا العام تخصص بشكل كبير لدعم الفتيات
الافغانيات اللواتي حرمنا من ابسط حقوق في
التعريف بالفعل يونسكو تنظم فاعليه في مقر
الامم المتحده بنيويورك والحلقه الاولى من
النقاش ستطالب اعاده حق الفتيات في
التعليم بعدما اغلق طالبان باب التعليم
الثانوي والجامع في وجهنا البيان مباشر لا
ينبغي ان يمنع اي او يمنع اي بلد في
العالم النساء والفتيات من الحصول على حق
التعليم هو حق عالمي من حقوق الانسان
واحترامه واجب يونسكو تعتبر وان حق
الافغانيات في التعلم هو مهمه تقع على
عاتق المجتمع الدولي باسره وان الحرب على
النساء يجب ان تتوقف فورا حاليا هناك اكثر
من مليون ونصف المليون فتاه وفتى خارج
التعليم في افغانستان ولا يبدو ان شيئا
سيتغير في القريب العاجل نحن في يوم
التعليم سنفتح زاويه اخرى هل قلت نفسك
اليوم وكل يوم هل ما زلت هو ما زلت او ما
زلت تتعلم اجابات وافكار مع هند ابراهيم
في واشنطن ونعود
[تصفيق]
التعلم في الصغر كالنقش على الحجر والتعلم
في الكبر كالنقشي على الماء هكذا تربينا
لكنها مقوله ربما تبعث على الكسل ولا عل
اهم سؤالي يمكن ان يساله الانسان مهما بلغ
عمره ماذا تعلمت اليوم
[موسيقى]
ولكن هل البالغون يستطيعون التعلم في اي
عمر الاجابه نعم والعلم يؤيد ذلك الدماغ
البشري قادر على استقبال المعلومات
الجديده ما دام الانسان يتنفس وبالنسبه
لكبار السن ما يمنعهم عن مواصله التعلم هو
اعتقادهم على الاغلب بانهم غير قادرين على
التعلم
[موسيقى]
الحالي يصبح التعلم اليومي فرضا لا خيارا
تخيلوا كل تلك التغييرات في عالم العمل كل
تلك الروبوتات القادمه كل تلك المنافسه مع
الذكاء الاصطناعي اذا كنت في الثلاثين او
الاربعين او الخمسين هل تستسلم لكونك قد
تصبح غيرنا
[موسيقى]
شركات عديده تؤمن بتدريب الموظفين داخليا
بشكل دوري مصطلحات مثلو ابن الشركه ونجاحك
من نجاح المؤسسه لا تستقيم بدون تعليم في
العمل وتعليم من دونها نهايه
ولعلنا نستذكر قول غاندي عش حياتك كانك
ستموت غدا وتعلم كانك ستعيش للابد لصباح
العربيه هند ابراهيم
[موسيقى]
على كل اللي تنضم الينا من القاهره مدربه
تصوير مهارات فاتن سلامه يسعد صباحك يا
فاتن اهلا بك معنا من جديد صباح العربيه
هل بامكان الموظف بالفعل ان يطور ويتعلم
ويطور مهاراته في مكان العمل
صباح الخير يا سهام صباح الخير نادين
وصباح الخير على كل المشاهدين نعم يستطيع
الموظف في اي وقت تطوير نفسه وتطوير اداء
ومهارات وخصوصا في العشر سنوات الاخيره
عندما تغير مفهوم قسم التدريب او
الترينينج بورتمان للتعليم والتطوير واضيف
عليه مصطلحات اخرى مثل او اداره المهارات
همم او اداره الكفاءات وبالتالي يستطيع
الموظف ويسترجعني قول همم فرانكلين
الفيلسوف عندما قال قل لي وسوف انسى علمني
وسوف اتعلم ولكن ان فولفنت او يعني ساعدني
في ان انا يكون عمليه التعليم او اليورنت
بروسيس فيها ان فولفونت او فيها ان انت
بتحطني في الموقع الصحيح علشان اقدر اتعلم
وما يكونش في فقط التعليم حبر على ورق اول
تدريب خليني بس كمان ندخل في نقاط هل يمكن
ان يكون الشخص بدون مقومات تذكر او من ضمن
المعايير التي يبني عليها وتستطيع الشركه
ان تستثمر فيه وتطور رغم عدم وجود موهبه
همم يعتمد على فكره ما هي الموهبه يا
نادين يعني كانت مكانزي وهي من اكبر شركات
الكونسيلتون الكونسيلتونسي او الاستشارات
كانت عملت سيرفي على 100 شركه ومن خلاله
اكد 70% من اللي اشتركوا في هذا التقييم
او في هذا السرفي اكدوا على ان التدريب
اللي بيحصلوا عليه ليس له علاقه بتطوير
المهاره او بالتطوير اداءهم الوظيفي
وبالتالي هو الفكره في ان انا كاترينر او
انا كمدرب لازم اعمل التقييم الصحيح
للموظف عشان اعرف الموظف ده محتاج ايه
علشان يفيد مكان العمل حتى لو الموظف ده
جاء لي بدون اي مهاره المهاره عكس الموهبه
المهاره يمكن بالتدريب الصحيح وما يطلق
عليها الان لين ليرننج بروستس يعني عمليه
التعليم اختيار التعليم الصحيح في الوقت
المناسب في ال- ال- المحتوى الصحيح للجروب
المناسب يعني يعني مش بس بعد انتهاء اليوم
الوظيفي او ان انا باجيب الموظف يوم القف
بتاعه ان هو ياخذ تدريب لا لازم يكون
عمليه التدريب او التعليم تكون لين طيب
فاتن كيف للشركات ان تستثمر في تطوير
مهارات موظف فيها هذه المره
مهم جدا السؤال ده وبيستا يعني برايم
استاذ الاقتصاد اللي قال انه همم للاسف
الادارات العليا الادارات العليا استاذ
الاقتصاد بجامعه همم جوج ميسن اكد على ان
الادارات العليا بتلجا الى همم مجموعه من
التدريبات علشان بس تحصل على كردت معين او
يضيفها يضفوها للسيفات بتاعتهم وبالتالي
ده ما يرهق الشركات
وبيستنزفه ملايين الدولارات لمجرد حصول
المدره على شهادات معينه كيف يمكن للموظف
للشركات تطوير مهارات الموظف اول حاجه ان
انا احدد التدريبات الاساسيه للموظف
بالاتفاق مع الموظف ان انت هتحصل على هذه
التدريبات للحصول على هذه المهاره الشيء
الثاني هو التطبيق التطبيق الميديات لاول
تطبيق المباشر ليه التطبيق المباشر لان
عالم النفس الالماني هيرمان قال لنا ان في
حاجه اسمها القرفينج فورجيتنج او منحنى ان
النسيان يعني موظف لو انا جبته لغرفه
التدريب بعد ست ايام لو ما طبقش اللي هو
تعلمه هينسى 75% وبالتالي الموظف بيطلع من
غرفه التدريب هي المفروض انه يطبق ما
تعلمه وثالث حاجه ادي له الفيت باك او ادي
له رايي المباشر او الراي اللي هو بيكون
بيبدا بشيء ايجابي وينتهي بشيء ايجابي وفي
المنتصف اقول له ايه هي الايريا اوف
انكروبنت او المساحه اللي يجب ان هو يطور
نفسه منها واعيد السيكل ثاني اهو طيب فاتن
يعني كلام جميل اللي عم بتقوليه اليوم في
شركات تعتمد الاستثمار بموهوبين في عمر
صغير رغم عدم وجود خبره ولكن تطويرهم
والاستثمار على المدى البعيد ايهما افضل
هذه الحاله ام استثمار باشخاص اصحاب مهاره
من اصحاب الخبره وتطويلهم شيء من خلال
الورشات والتدريب
انا هقول ان احنا نعمل مسجد ما بين
الاثنين وما وده المصطلح اللي انا بستخدمه
في غرفه التدريب اطلق عليه البير لورنينج
ان انا الجيل الجديد اللي جاي ما عندوش
مهاره ومعندوش خبره ببدا اعلمه من مش بس
من خلال غرفه التدريب لا من خلال ذو
الخبره اللي موجودين في مكان العمل ده
بيحسن من العلاقه بين الجلين بيخلي فيه
كده جسر تواصل ما بين الجلين بيحسن اا او
بيعزز الثقه بالنفس للجيل القديم اللي انا
باقول له انا جايبه احد من الجيل الجديد
اللي الملينيال اللي عارف اللي عارف
تكنولوجيا وعارف وعارف وعارف فبالتالي ده
بحبته لا انت اللي هتعلمه انا هاستخدم هذه
يعني هاستخدم خبراتك ومهاراتك همم في مجال
العمل وده بنسميه
الانشبت رينج اللي هو انا لما باطلع
الموظف من غرفه التدريب بيكون فيه شادو
معه من هؤلاء ذو الخبره واا ذو يعني
السنين الطويله في مجال العمل
عمليه ان انا امزج ما بين الجيل الجديد
والجيل الحديد همم ده بيعمل همم بيكون له
اثر جيد جدا على الاداء في الشركات وفقد
تعقيب سريع النجاح لا يتحقق الا عندما
يخرج الانسان من منطقه الراحه من الكونفد
زون تبعه هنا تكمن التحديات في الحياه
ويتطور الانسان شكرا شكرا جزيلا فاتن
سلامه مدربه تطوير مهارات نورتنا يا فاتن
شكرا لك